desde el lunes a la noche los
legisladores habían estado celebrando el
alivio económico que venía por fin en
camino la ley de gasto que incluye los
tan necesitados cheques de alivio fue
aprobada con un margen amplio y
bipartidista pero donald trump difundió
un vídeo en twitter amenazando con
bloquear lo logrado
pido al congreso que enmiende esta ley
de gasto y aumente la ridícula cantidad
de seiscientos dólares a dos mil a
cuatro mil para las parejas
el trino de donald trump llegó como una
bomba
los demócratas han estado ansiosos por
incluir un pago más alto pero los
republicanos se negaron a la idea y la
administración de trump ha formado parte
de los meses de negociaciones
nancy pelosi contestó en redes sociales
al presidente diciendo que ella quiere
incrementar las ayudas del hobbit 19
los republicanos se negaron
repetidamente a decir qué cantidad
quería el presidente para los cheques
directos finalmente el presidente ha
decidido dos mil dólares y los
demócratas están listos para llevarlo a
la cámara y firmarlo la próxima semana
por consenso unánime hagámoslo
el propio trump pone ahora en aprietos a
su propio partido respecto al paquete de
ayudas de 900.000 millones que es parte
de una ley de gasto de más de 5000
páginas por 2.3 billones de dólares
mientras que trump no ha dicho que
vetará la ley cosa que si hiciera podría
ser derogada por el congreso lo cierto
es que despierta especulaciones es este
un gesto para complacer a su base un
intento por permanecer en el foco de
atención en todo caso trump silencio
rápidamente cualquier felicitación de
navidad del capitolio